so I'll be talking about arrays and
particularly beyond numpy arrays and
where I'm coming from this coming from
in this is I'm part of an NSF program to
improve software used by high-energy
physicists so so that's my my charge in
all of this that's where all this is
coming from and where it's motivated but
I think that what we'll be talking about
here is a broader interest than that
however since it is the motivation for
the problem I should at least start by
talking about what is it that we're
doing and so you've probably seen
pictures like this some people might
have it like you know sometimes
background you're a laptop or a poster
or something it's a it's a photo of some
atomic particles traveling through a
detector and this one is from 1964 a
group from Berkeley scanned through a
hundred thousand photos to find this one
this one is special it's the discovery
of the Omega berry on which was a
pivotal point in discovering quarks so
then look at that you see it go through
a hundred thousand photos that look most
more or less like this and I find it
well it helps if you draw the lines on
top so each one of these pictures has to
be interpreted so you see all those
tracks on there most of them don't have
to do with the event of interest and
then it's a matter of finding the ones
that do and interpreting it and the
interpretation is itself pretty
complicated this is an Omega decays to
accede case to a lump decays to two
photons and pi ons and protons and you
know and you have to go through a
hundred thousand to find these so just
in a nutshell this is what particle
physicists do even today this is what we
do we collide particles produce new ones
and take pictures of the decays so we
can interpret them it's you know what
what have we produced
and unfortunately these part of these
pictures come unlabeled so here's a
modern one you know so you look at that
you say oh yeah I see something maybe so
since you know the old days things have
basically just scaled up it's the same
kind of problem but going from
photographs to digital scans the number
of events is now you know at the
trillion level obviously we're no longer
manual or semi-automated it's fully
automatic even machine learning is
involved in that and also in a number of
people involved this is huge so how do
you algorithmically find decay such as
that that chain we started with well it
involves loops you loop over all pairs
of particle tracks and you just
tentatively call them pi plus pi minus
just assume that they are calculates the
special relativity mass that they would
have if they came from a single particle
decay and if that mass is close to a
known mass they will pile up you know
the ones that are truly that decay peak
at the known at the true mass and the
ones that aren't and they're just random
junk there everywhere else so so that's
it you just do that all the way down the
chain such as for instance Higgs to Z Z
Z to EE or Z to Miu Miu so for the Higgs
discovery mmm six years ago and then
shows up as a peak
brand-new peak okay so from a
computational point of view so that was
the motivation now let's think about the
computation one of the great advantages
we have is that all the events are
independent so no particles from one DK
will live long enough to to be in the
next decay or at least it won't stay in
the detector long enough it'll fly away
[Music]
the detectors produce collections of
different
kinds of signals tracks like we've seen
but also energy depositions timing and
then you know when we partially analyze
these we put them in different buckets
these are the electrons these are the
muons these are something else and each
of these has a variable length
collection variable length per event if
we were to do this with SQL and we don't
this is kind of the mindset that it
would be the decay candidates can be
thought of as like a self join if we're
combining two things in the same
collection or like a cross join if we're
combining things from different
collections but here's the kicker
always-on event ID 1 equals event ID 2
it's always in the same event and that's
basically why we don't use SQL we'd be
saying that every single with every
single join and then after we found
candidates the good candidates are
identified by filtering throwing away
the bad or some sort of a reduction like
in the functional programming sense to
find the best of what remains like
maximum sum something like that so
here's sort of the diagram of how it
goes first we'll have some sort of per
event to join and then we map some
calculation across all of those
candidates we filter to pick the best
ones you know we filter to find that the
ok ones and then we reduce to find the
best one independently for each event uh
another kibum can't say this enough it's
a large number of events and then each
event within the event has an arbitrary
number of record like structures so
we'll have like a muon record that has
values of you know various attributes PT
a to Phi and then we'll have several of
them and this is not reducible to a
single flat table without some sort of
padding or loss so if we tried to turn
this into a single table then we would
have to say oh mu 1 PT mu 2 PT and if
there isn't a Mew 2 well then you've
filled with Na and if there is a Mew 3
well you've lost it so so this so we
don't want to do that lossy
transformation until it may be the very
last stage of some particular analysis
and then the programming landscape is I
would say rather conservative it wasn't
until the late 90s early 2000s that we
switched from Fortran to C++ and only
right now that we are starting to use
Python seriously in fact you can see
this transition happening right now I
did some github statistics I selected
users who are definitely physicists
because they they forked a particular
repository and then I looked at what are
the languages of choice for their other
repositories the ones they didn't fork
and since physicists started using
github in 2013 and to a large degree
it's slowly been transitioning from
primarily C and C++ projects to now more
Python and Jupiter and this year is the
turnover point so in our field the
conventional analysis means you write
loops on objects allocated on the heap
in the C++ line so this is what the
finding the two pi ons to find the K on
looks like it's just C++ loops we fill
STD vector and such a direct translation
to Python would be a performance
disaster and in many cases this is
exactly what people do and it is a
performance disaster because you know
Python objects are doing a lot of string
comparisons and such so for
high-performance computing in in Python
usually the first thing you think of as
well we should you use numpy numpy if
you're not familiar is a library it's
very it's almost it's an almost standard
library almost everything is uses it if
you've ever used or heard of pandas
pandas uses it heavily and the objects
in the in the Python world are really
just pointers to big buffers and the
Python objects interpret those those
buffers as
raise numpy comes with a suite of
operations that apply to whole arrays so
if you want to do something like compute
P Z is PT times cinch Aveda just that's
something that you might want to compute
you can put individual numbers in there
you can put one PT and one ADA you know
one number in each and it'll compute
that and give you one number back or you
can give a whole array of pts and a
whole array of ADA's it'll compute that
and give you a whole array of PZ back
and that's where you get the the speed
in Python is that you're not doing very
many Python statements and you're not
using very many Python objects most of
the stuff is some compiled and probably
vectorized loop in NC another new thing
about Python is sorry another neat thing
about numpy is that the interpret the
the object that interprets the array can
change leaving the array in place
without without changing the array at
all so just changing this shape and
Strides parameter you can do all sorts
of crazy slices of these rectangular
arrays without actually touching the
data the big data at least but numpy
doesn't have anything for unequal length
lists and this is fundamental to our
field you know it goes all the way back
to the 60s so we can't get away with it
we need something we don't have anything
in numpy that could take a whole lot of
events each with different sized
collections and do something like you
know find all the all the pairs there
are libraries that represent a raise of
unequal lengths this is becoming more
and more popular I've known notice that
this used to be just one library and
then you know they're more for being
able to deal with this and so this is a
good sign and if you're thinking about
this and if you're thinking in terms of
traditional data structures where you
have like a C++ class or
our struct and then STD vectors of them
it can be surprising to find that you
can take those objects and actually
slice them the other way instead of
making a bunch of objects this way just
somehow sliced them this way if that
makes any sense so we look at the
diagram here we can slice them in such a
way that we can make an array that
consists of just one field just all the
values for that one field all the way
across and same thing for the next field
and same thing for the next field and
this has lost all of the structure which
of those values belongs to which
particle in which event and so then you
can have another array represent that
structure so for instance you could have
mean the simplest thing to do would be
to just have the account and discount
says oh the first three of those values
belong in the first event and the next
one value pullings in the next event and
the next one value belongs in the next
event and then two values in the last
event that's nice except it's not random
access so you can just cumulative summit
to to get offsets and then you can jump
to any one that you want furthermore
that offsets is sort of folded together
starting positions and stopping
positions and sometimes it's useful to
separate those out and have two separate
arrays for that and sometimes it's
useful to have instead of pointers down
from the parents to the child pointers
up from the child to the parent and that
if if you're in the SQL world is
normalized table it's like a normalized
foreign key it's useful for some
operations and others of these are
useful for other operations so a lot of
what these libraries do and a lot of
what I just showed you actually it's
just representing the jagged data in a
columnar way but now let's talk about
manipulations so we'll just start with a
simple one just to to illustrate what
kind of power that we that we have now
that we didn't have with
non columnar data so let's say the thing
that you want to do is you want to
remove the first muon from each event
remove the first particle from each of
that you just want to drop it and keep
the rest well if you have traditional
data structures that means you have to
rewrite those lists but if you have a
columnar data structure particularly if
it's like starts and stops you see that
you didn't have to touch any of the the
content you can just change the number
of where they begin for this particular
operation and then other operations do
other tricks but yeah so we've got a
whole bunch of new tricks available if
we have the data represented this way
and a really nice thing about this is
what if the contents what if all of the
attributes corresponding to my particle
let's say I have a hundred of them and a
given physics analysis this particular
analyzer is going to touch at most ten
of them and then that analyzer is going
to touch a different ten well you can if
you additionally make those content
arrays lazy loading then you can do all
sorts of manipulations on your particles
without even reading them from disk so
properties of column air data
I didn't prove it but these they are
fully composable so you could for
instance say a jagged erase content is
not just flat numbers it's another
jagged array and you can keep doing that
all the way down and you can do that in
an arbitrary complex ways in addition
you can do more than just jaggedness
non-driven on trivial data types like
heterogeneous you know so you might be
thinking like a tagged union nullable
types pointers the one thing it has to
be is it has to be statically type of
all it can't be completely dynamic data
you have to know ahead of time what is
the type and most operations beyond just
the slicing example I showed can modify
the structure the structure a so the
counts of the offsets of the start stops
of the parents that the things I showed
you in red without touching the
content so awkward array is a library
that does this it provides operations on
columnar data with a numpy like
interface so you could take for instance
that monstrosity so that that data looks
looks terrible it's got all sorts of
nuns in it it's one of these the 4.4 and
the racket 5.5 it's it's breaking
pattern it has some some tables in it
that I'm representing with Jason like
dictionaries and you can ingest it into
a columnar array so following some
recursive rules turned into columns and
then you can do numpy like things on it
you can like if you're familiar with
numpy syntax the way that you would
slice the second but not first a
dimension of an array is you would put a
colon for the first dimension and then
like - 2 colon to say the last two of
the the next dimension and it'll just do
that verify that just speaking the last
two and you can apply array at a time
operations like you could take the Cinch
of everything or you could add a hundred
to everything or any of the the numpy
you funks just pass down through these
nested structures and apply at the
lowest level so I'm here I'm showing the
original data structure with everything
plus 100 the layout of this how what is
this actually in memory it's a bunch of
Python classes that contain numpy arrays
so so the depth of this structure you
can see jagged array index max array for
the masking Union array for the
heterogeneous lists all these different
kinds of structures but at the leaves at
the bottom of all this it's just numpy
arrays and that's in that sense it's
colander and data types we want to be
able to describe data types so the way
that we're actually describing those
data types as we say well you know array
indexing is like a function
you know you have square brackets a set
of round brackets but you can put
something in there and if that's a
number then you get an an element if
that's a string then you can get a
column from it and so then since and
then you can talk about the the datatype
like a functional data type like this is
intentionally made to look like Haskell
function data type of this arrow that
arrow that arrow that to show what
happens if you put in a number here what
kind of structured yet if you put a
number here what kind of structure you
get you get a tree in general and here's
a point that is really an aside but I
want to take advantage of my time at
strange loop with people who know these
things we've found that you know arrays
are functions in general and array
indexing is function composition and in
fact it's associative just like function
composition and that's been really
useful in our work if anyone can tell me
more afterward about it like if there's
any literature on this I really like to
know this is just a sort of the thing
that we discovered by by tinkering with
this and I bet there's like a
mathematical theory of it and I want to
learn anyway that's an aside it's way
too much detail so let's get back to the
main point what kinds of things can you
use this for so let's look at some real
data and some not particle physics data
first change completely far afield
somewhere somewhere you know way way out
there and let's consider a space data so
look at the exoplanets data set and I
like this data set because it's
naturally jagged a star can have more
than one planet so we ingest that from a
JSON file because adjacent file is a
rather natural way to represent these
structures and let's look at just one of
them or two of them I guess and you can
see that among the the the fields in
this data one of the fields is planets
which is a list of more objects so this
is the this is what the data means but
the data is in a columnar representation
this data type is easier to read than
the the monstrosity I showed earlier if
you put in a number less than 2900
something you will get a star and a star
has all of those fields and if you put
in the field name for right ascension or
distance or mass you'll get the Stars
right ascension or distance or mass and
those are numbers or if you put in the
string planets you get a list of objects
that have their own properties
so in well-behaved cases not ridiculous
cases this is kind of readable some of
the numpy ash things you might want to
do you might want to just select all the
star masses because you're going to
compute something you might want to
select all the planet masses now look at
this that's that's a jagged or it has a
nested structure some of these like the
the second-to-last has three items in it
because there are three planets in the
second-last in this data set and we have
sort of projected through the planets
structure to pick out just the mass so
we look at the the data types for this
the star type is rather simple
you put an integer you get a nullable
float some of them are none you know
some of them missing you put in stars of
planets of mass and you get this jagged
array of numbers you put in a number
less than this out of them you put in a
number who knows because it's jagged and
you get a null will float so this
projection slices through rows instead
of slit sorry slices through columns
instead of slicing through rows which is
a very natural thing if it's rectangular
tabular data but you can also do it in a
jacket case and another nice
mathematical property of this is that
this means that putting strings and
square brackets and putting numbers and
square brackets commute you can switch
the order of the strings and the numbers
you can't switch the order of a number
in a number or string in a string so
any property it's it's really natural if
you had a if you had a rectangular table
you can specify the column before the
row or the row before the column and you
expect to get the same thing in each
case it generalizes to jacket cases II
you can represent this data with pandas
so maybe maybe somebody who's really
into data science and has been using
pandas for everything would say well you
know I could probably represent this
this exoplanets dataset and pandas and
yes that's true you could take the you
could take the jaggedness
that I had in you know was representing
by the square brackets and put that into
the index so you see in this that we
just turned into a panda's data frame
you see that the the the second to last
has three planets because there's
there's a entry in a sub entry column at
the left in fact it has some some nice
properties jaggedness in the awkward
arrays goes to multi index rose and
nested tables in the jagged array goes
to multi index columns that's kind of
neat why don't we just use P and s well
we often have to deal with differently
jagged collections you know we'll have
two electrons and one muon or you know
fifteen jets or you know these different
types of particles in the same event and
so if we try to have my mouse here
differently jagged things we can project
out and get a table for each one either
one of them but we can't get a table for
both of them because a data frame can
have only one index you can have and if
so if we were trying to live in that
world we'd find that we would be merging
all the time we'll be doing nothing but
merging there are other packages as I
said earlier that represent can
represent jagged arrays and in some
cases like Apache arrow and X and D they
have very complete type systems X and
even has pointers which is nice in fact
our own software this root package goes
back to the late 90s when we were making
this C++ transition and it represents
all of the data as jagged columns on
disk so it was like we were almost you
know we're almost there
but when it loads it into memory it
turns them into C++ objects so here
we're just going one step further and
leaving them in that jagged form when
they're in memory so what I'm trying to
do here is I'm not with the awkward
array package we're not trying to
replace those other packages in fact we
want to be able to interact with them
very well we want to transform back and
forth to all these different formats so
our focus is not input/output or even
numerical math as it is in the case of X
and D it's the structure manipulation
that we have to deal with all the time
we couldn't in fact use any of those
libraries as is so some examples of this
there's no chip time ok this was the
example I started with say you want to
compute masses of particles like a goes
XY or B goes to xx traditionally you
have to write loops and then the
structure of those loops depends on
whether you're picking from the same
collection you don't want duplicates or
not so as a array manipulation now we
have primitives for this you know
because we're doing it all the time we
want to be able to say data set X cross
data set Y to get the cross join per
event or a data set X choose two to pick
two without replacement and so you know
I just replaced them with function calls
those function calls are themselves
implemented with a bunch of numpy tricks
so not not to study this deeply this is
no point in here do we have like a for
loop
it's all just numb pyon pyon pyon pyon
umpire and even the the choose thing I'm
just flabbergasted that there was a that
there's a vectorized you know pure numpy
solution to it and in fact it's limited
by the fact that algebraically you can't
solve the quintic which I think it's
hilarious anyway it's my favorite
software limitation if we wanted to do a
size bigger than five we have to write
loops other examples like filtering I
said that was the next step you want to
do let's say we want to filter these
particles well now you have a choice do
you want to remove particles from events
what do you want to remove events so
there have to be different ways of
expressing that and with loops there are
different ways that you write that out
long handed loops and and just as a
byproduct of generalizing them PI's
rules we get these these cute little
expressions like like this where you put
a mask in square brackets and that mask
is made by you know greater than cut or
max greater than cut and those and the
first one is cutting particles the
second cutting events for this reason if
you're familiar with numpy you've
probably made a raise of boolean's and
passed them inside the square brackets
to select elements of the array we can
do that here even if the elements they
are variable length things and we can
also do that if we have a jagged mask
and it has the natural extension and in
this case here where we said events a
max greater than cut that is a reduction
the maximum is reducing the jagged rate
to a flat array and then it's a boolean
there it comes out in a nice way
similarly I think I'm going to hurry
along now the the part of the problem of
reduction is similarly made
similarly simplified by
the fact that we're just generalizing
what numpy already does to the jagged
case physicists are come up with much
harder problems than these you know
these examples are deliberately
simplified but this is an example
problem statement and you know looking
at a statement like this I know you're
going to read it makes us think that
maybe we want domain-specific language
and so here's a an attempt at a sql-like
domain-specific language for trying to
express some of these really complicated
selections but on the other hand when
you do that in loops like the way people
are doing it now it's pages and that's
you know what currently makes research
art this is not a hypothetical package
or used by only a couple of people we've
been it's been sort of in the wild for a
year now these are our tip download
statistics so we're tracking how people
using it with the selection that they're
on scientific list Linux systems which
means that they are physicists so just
picking the physicists just picking the
physicists awkward is this purple line
when it was made a dependency of this
red line and so people are bringing in
the the package to just read their files
and they're getting the the awkward
arrays along for the ride but within
this world within this small world
there's as many downloads of this as
matplotlib or panas we now have a lot of
these composable things we just compose
them to get all sorts of different
features and what do we want to do now
now that we you know successful now we
want to rewrite it all now we've got a
lot of feedback from the users we
there's some design changes we want we
also want to we want a C++ version of
this so they can interface with existing
code a lot of which is written in C++ we
want to be able to use number
because that would be fantastic if
people could write Python expressions
and just should compile them and and do
in those expert in those functions were
aware of this stuff but you know this if
we're imagining writing three versions
of this one numpy one c++ one number
it's beyond our abilities so and we also
want to fix some design mistakes that
we're learning from people using and the
feedback and so we have an idea of
building it in layers with a substrate
written and see where the actual
algorithms go and then c++ or a number
where you have memory management and
then that's PI bind 11 into Python and
so this is these are our plans this is
what we're working on now finally like
is this only for particle physics I
would say no otherwise I wouldn't even
come here and tell you about it the
existence of arrow and xnd and the
momentum behind these projects suggests
that it's not so that's the data
structures well how could that be
domain-specific we have found another
example at least in the sciences where
this join map filter reduce workflow is
highly relevant in genetics and we found
this out because we found out that ZAR
are however you pronounce that czar the
tsar library has ragged arrays and the
reason they need them is for genetics
and then finally you know I've been
looking at this sim D Jason package
which is awesome it parses Jason super
fast if we could couple this with the
from itter and turn the Jason into
columnar data
how many Jason datasets are there out
there you know maybe a log data or
something like that semi-regularly that
you want to just ingest into a much
smaller form and perform much faster
operations on so leave that out to you
too there any ideas and finally there
are a lot of people are contributing to
this we're getting
functions written by users and and I've
had a lot of great conversations with
the arrow and the xnd team and the SAR
team so I want to acknowledge them so
that's it thanks
[Applause]